I don't know this is why my search
history on the Internet is premium value
because I'm Googling weird stuff like
that
this episode of ATI is brought to you by
curve make sure you stick around to the
end to get the latest offer from
curve.com I'm Emma Willman and I am here
to answer the internet how long would it
take you to eat your own
how long would it take you to eat your
own body weight and hot dogs I was
trying to buy Time by pretending I
didn't read it right it would take me uh
four hours no yeah I'm 130 pounds so how
many pounds of hot dogs in four hours
yeah you think it'll take me longer or
shorter yeah so much how many how much
is one hot how much is a pound of hot
dogs 15 uh 15 hot dogs on one pound no
25 hot dogs and one pound getting
triggered from the SATs I bet there's a
hundred hot dogs in one pound
oh I'm an idiot so you have to have one
from 300 hot dogs if a gun to my head a
thousand hot dogs I could do it in 24
hours
I'm kind of a war I'll do it again
how long would it take you I think a
thousand hot dogs would take me like a
week what a gun to your head I'm gonna
kill your mother you would eat it in a
week I'm gonna kill your mother I've
ever eaten like in one sitting like the
most four yeah like four but gun to your
head like if someone's like I'm gonna
kill your sister I've been crying and
[ __ ] she said you need a thousand
hot dogs
24 hours a thousand how long would it
take you if every time you finish sex a
song played what song would you want it
to be
take it to the house by Trick Daddy
[Applause]
how long could you last on the run after
robbing a bank eight minutes yeah like
I'm an idiot I'm an absolute I would
walk out take a wrong turn I'd call the
cops on myself because I got confused
eight no I mean not even I wouldn't make
it to the bank there's no way I would be
like texting people like I'm gonna rob a
bank do you think this is a good idea
like it would be a be a mess if there
was a database of your lifetime internet
history
how much money would it take for you to
make it public
[ __ ] uh I'd say 80 grand yeah 80 grand
the thing it wouldn't be the porn that
I'm most concerned about because I'm
pretty like open about that like but I
probably in a state okay I Googled what
an actual day in jail is like because I
wanted to kill somebody one time
kicked in and so then I was like I don't
actually want to do it because I don't
actually hurt them but I do want to kill
them you know what I'm saying I was
pissed
would you rather have free strippers for
life or free pizza for life I'm gonna
say strippers and then I would tell
people they could come hang out with me
in the strippers if they bring me some
pizza
are you a strip club girl no I get
anxiety at them I feel bad because I
feel like I don't want to make the
strippers uncomfortable thinking I'm
looking at them one time I went to a
strip club and I had my eyes down and
then this girl came over and she had a
lazy eye and she asked me for a dance
and I didn't want her to think that I
wasn't giving her a dance because she
had a lazy eye so I let her do the dance
and I just gave her all my money which
was 300 bucks I didn't know the rate of
strip club dances so then she was like
circling those yeah not good with
numbers I was like you're great you're
great it's me not you you're great like
I think a hot chick with a lazy eye is
the perfect stripper because if I get
some sympathy yeah she wasn't as hot as
the other ones also nothing to do with
the lazy eye but there was other stuff
going on and then I noticed I was like
can you use a gift card on a first date
no absolutely not no way there's no way
or here's the thing
here's the thing the girl can't know
you're doing that but also if you did
use a gift card and she knew and she had
a problem with it and she's a bad person
that's what I'm saying you know what
then what the [ __ ]
I feel you know what you're okay here's
the thing I need to say no just but you
know I'm in a relationship so there's no
more future first dates for me so I
would publicly say no but then like if I
actually did need to do that and then
the girl had a problem with it I'd like
you [ __ ] monster so yes of course do
whatever you need to do to take care of
yourself financially and also go on a
date of course if you had to win a game
show to stay alive which game show would
you choose [ __ ] I'd be [ __ ] this is
the problem I don't know things so it'd
be like and my only talents are
networking dirty talk and I can and used
to be shoplifting as a child
uh if I had to win it to stay alive I
guess I would choose
I would choose Naked and Afraid
if you had to pick one person to be the
ambassador for the human race to meet
Aliens who would it be it Nelson Mandela
did he ever get in trouble for anything
right
yeah and be like don't mess with us also
yeah right like we all look like him
right yeah exactly yeah actually I said
my mom because she is just so sweet and
she's like well yeah I'm the Ambassador
I don't know why my daughter picked the
whole thing and it was just I said my
mom if you could be Master at one of the
four bases of sex but you'd have to be
below average at every other base which
one would you choose to be the master it
would be doing butt stuff because I feel
like more people have less practice at
that so that I would excel at that
sexually addict my thing wait what are
that is it I would say I don't know I
guess we'll be like kissing
breasts going down on and then strap on
stuff and then snap on considered like
the sex but here's the thing for me I'm
very into that but I don't know how most
lesbians have sex literally I've been
with other lesbians want to be like how
do you guys have sex like I don't know
for me that is like oriented on that but
but like me do me because I would feel
like I would then me on the girl or guys
it's like the sex is the the big so you
wouldn't consider it for girls like
you're you're strapping on a fake dick
it's like is that that fun it's pretty
fun yeah
yeah
yeah
come from that yeah because it's like
pushing on you yeah or they have like
lots of like like yeah yeah but then
also like I would consider like butt
like anal stuff I would consider not
like an app like that would say like
it's like one two three four that'd be
like level like six that is but not
penetrating about stuff like I always my
trick with butt stuff used to always be
you want to make the girl think it's
their idea
[Laughter]
you always like put like pressure and
like massage their button way so then
they start backing into it more and then
they're backing into it enough that you
can do that then you make them think
that that's like they're setting the
agenda
switch to each other I feel like
but it but you have to if they think
it's their idea then you're not pushing
it too and then you have to be like oh
and you also have to always like do like
like oral and finger stuff before you do
anything bigger in the butt because
that's they have to trust you so much
would you rather have a girl who talked
a lot during sex or a girl who is
completely silent during it talked a lot
for sure I mean it kind of obviously
depends what she's talking about like if
she was like you need to do your taxes
I'd be like but if she talks about
sexually talking over quiet for sure if
you had to move it to a different place
on the body where would you put the
vagina
I would put it right below the breast so
you could be touching the nipple and
like the vagina easier
or I would put it someplace like on
their side so if you're touching it in
public not everybody knows but just you
know you know what I'm saying
exactly look you see all this nonsense
look at all these cards look at all this
[ __ ] that I have in here don't need any
of that when you got yourself a curve
card look at this it's from the UK it's
the new [ __ ] where you can take all the
stuff in your wild all the cards in your
wallet and put it right on one curve
card you can also get curved points
while you still get the points from your
other cards that way you get twice as
much go to curve.com parcel right now
get twenty dollars in curved cash terms
and conditions apply would you rather
have to watch a sex tape of your parents
every day for the rest of your life or
watch every game your sports team plays
and they lose every time I would rather
watch every game my sports team plays
and lose every time 100 hands down yeah
for sure no one's trying to I would
watch my parents have sex for money
though
I'm curious I'm a little curious they
got divorced soon after and I'm curious
if they ever bonded sexually or not I
don't know this is why my search history
on the Internet is premium value because
I'm Googling weird stuff like that
do my parents love each other
thank you for watching answer the
internet please remember to subscribe to
the channel
set reminders with a little bell comment
who you want to see do it and watch all
the other answer the internets I don't
know where anything is so I'm kind of
just moving my hands around but do all
that [ __ ] subscribe comment reminder
watch others you're welcome don't know
why but you're welcome